salut maroni est prévue aujourd'hui
bonjour ericsson aujourd'hui on découvre
un super à disposition pour nos sportifs
de haut niveau à super comment s'appelle
le dispositif c'est l'aide aux sportifs
de haut niveau tu verras ce dispositif
comprend trois types d' aide
individuelle ça m'intéresse pas aux
nutriments plus si beau si oui découvert
d'autres sportifs de haut niveau
suivez-moi
[Musique]
c'est ici au terrain de sainte thérèse
comme ça le retrouver demetri parade et
médaillée paralympique en 2020 à tokyo
dimitri bénéficié de l'aide de sportifs
de haut niveau par toi sa rencontre
avant de savoir un peu plus ce
dispositif
aujourd'hui mais très bon je veux voir
une symétrie racontez nous comment
l'aide aux sportifs de haut niveau il ya
dao d'autres projets professionnels
alors bon le dispositif est un
dispositif qui aide à la mobilité donc
invités quittent la métropole ce que mes
vives à toulouse donc venir à voir mais
ma famille tous les amis à la réunion il
ya deux mois après par - ici parce qu'il
connaît très bien que ma besoin de la
chaleur prépare - et mais financièrement
il aide à moins d'an préparation
paralympiques et grosses compétitions
internationales et en parlant de
performance mais aussi la prime à la
performance il ya évidemment
heureusement heureusement qu'à la prime
à la performance donc oui bah il ya la
prime personnelle record personnel
homologué ya la prime sélection des jeux
paralympiques et aprimo la tranche pas
d'europe championnat du monde et la
prime des jeux courriel le plus complet
et le plus dans ce dispositif déjà moins
en a besoin de chaleur près par mois et
pour être au top à chaque fois me viens
on va continuer mes entraînements ici
d'accord rôle en métropole compétition
et fait exploser rocco mais le truc qui
plaît vraiment le plus c'est de pouvoir
rentrer tous les ans est sûre que le
billet les prix et surtout que bana y
impose pour moi une durée mais c'est
dimitri relativement rooney exclusion
depuis 1990 le département grâce à
l'aide de sportifs de haut niveau permet
à des jeunes sportifs locaux d'être
supervisé par les cadres techniques
nationaux de tenir et les effets de
l'éloignement et à maintenir un bon
niveau de compétitivité chez nos
athlètes pays
bonjour ironie gère edano qui peut
bénéficier de cette aide est sportif de
haut niveau l'aide aux sportifs de haut
niveau que propose deux départements la
réunion permet à des sportifs qui sont
inscrits sur liste de haut niveau ou
alors qu'ils sont dans une subtile
reconnu de haut niveau de bénéficier
d'une aide pour les accompagner vers des
compétitions ou à laon pour intégrer des
structures de haut niveau
comment fonctionne t tête justement la
départementale comporte trois volets un
premier volet qui portent sur la
mobilité des sportifs on assure le
règlement du billet d'avion à 100% pour
le sportif le deuxième volet est une
aide financière que propose le
département directement aux sportifs
qu'ils soient libérés de ces contraintes
matérielles de frais de déplacement ou
alors de frais d'équipement ou de frais
de stage l'aide à la performance le
sportif qui réalisent des podiums au
niveau national la paix me var et 260
euros à 3000 euros et comment prétendre
bénéficier de cette aide aux sportifs de
haut niveau pour bénéficier de l'aide le
sportif donc tout simplement aller sur
le site annales du département de ce
département 9 7 4 points fr ou alors ils
appellent le service du département le
service des sports qui prend en charge
l'instruction de sa demande mais
assiégée merci moroni
grâce à cet accompagnement du
département nos athlètes profitent d'un
vrai coup de pot soit maintenir un bon
niveau de compétitivité en effet les
règles de fixation des quotas par
discipline ne favorise pas l'inscription
des sportifs ultramarins ils ont donc
moins de chance d'être supervisé par les
cadres techniques nationaux
si vous souhaitez avoir plus
d'informations sur l'aide aux sportifs
de haut niveau n'hésitez pas vous avez
toutes les coordonnées qui s'affiche sur
votre écran le département des
générations c'est fini si vous souhaitez
ou avoir cet épisode ainsi free
d'épisodes précédents rendez vous sur
nos sites et nos réseaux sociaux quant à
moi serons tous très vite pas nouvel
épisode à bientôt
la semaine prochaine nous irons village
corail rencontré la famille richard
grasa la tl l'aide aux temps libres
proposées par la caf cette famille
profite de ses vacances dans un
établissement du département au coeur de
la station balnéaire de l'île
[Musique]